what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 1st of september the
renters do [__] and
it's a month away from the many saints
in newark no more [__] around the
joint is brought to you by draftkings
the nfl and college football is back
jack
you're getting paid like a [__]
hooker on friday night
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the nfl is giving all
new players a hell of an offer you ready
for this for the first week which is
next week you can bet a dollar on any
game and cash 200
and free bets
instantly no matter what draftkings is
giving all new players 200 bucks and
free bets
when you place a dollar bet on any
week one game where you're gonna get
that type of deal at nowhere
that's why i'm with draftkings
put down the [__] hummus and take
advantage of this limited time offer
head to draftkings sportsbook but start
by downloading draftking sportsbook app
and check out all their great promotions
and daily odd boosts plus a [__]
casino that's tremendous blackjack poker
roulette you got it but it starts with
you downloading the draftking sportsbook
app today use promo code joey to receive
203 bets when you place a dollar bet on
any week one game
[Music]
that's [__] insanity promo code joey
to get you 200
and free bets for a limited time only at
draftking sportsbook you got to be 21
older new jersey indiana or pennsylvania
only new customers only
restrictions do apply
see draftkings.com
sportsbook
for details now if you got a gaming
problem call 1-800 gambler if you're in
indiana call 1-809 with it
but if not if you're set and ready to go
download the draftking sportsbook app
and let's win some [__] getus you're
gonna need it for christmas this year
[__] the joint is also brought to
you by stamps.com
you know how much more time you'd have
and money you saved with stamps.com
you're still going to the [__] post
office aren't you and i bet you're still
paying full price for postage too that's
why i use stamps.com send letters ship
packages anytime
anywhere right from your computer with
stamps.com you pay a whole lot less you
get discounts up to 40 percent off the
post office rates and up to 66 offer ups
rates the discounts at stamps.com just
keep getting better now you're looking
at me going joey i got a small business
that's even better for you because you
don't have that much time and employees
stamps.com is a must-have my wife has it
we've been doing it from day one that's
how we send the shirts cups hats all
that [__] out so do me a favor you can
print us postage for any letter package
any class of mail
it's no wonder over a million small
businesses have already used stamps.com
ship anywhere in the world
straight from your laptop stop wasting
time going to the post office
go to stamps.com instead it's no risk
use promo code joey to get a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and
a digital scale who takes care of you
like that nobody stamps.com go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page and type in
joey
j-o-e-y that stamps dot com
promo code joey stamps.com
you'll never ever go to the [__] post
office again [__] those [__]
the joint is also brought to you by bowl
and branch listen
there's nothing more important than a
good night's sleep period
bowling branch
knows it takes more than just a good
[__] mattress you gotta have nice
smooth comfortable sheets bowling brand
sheets are ultra soft like cotton plus
they're 100 organic and sustainably
produced listen to me
my wife's got two sets of these sheets
they're always on the bed
comfortable cool it breeds
check out the signature ham series
they're the best sellers for good reason
they get softer with every wash you're
the guys that were asking me what do i
get my mom what do i get my dad what do
i get my aunt what do i get my
grandmother
this is it it's perfect for all seasons
and there's nothing better to help
someone help you sleep bowling brand
sheets are made by craftsmen these
workers and pay and respect that they
deserve
now listen get ready for this the
bowling branch guarantee enjoy any
product worry free for up to 30 nights
that's right there'll tell you a lot
to experience the best sheets you've
ever felt choose bowling branch you
could try them worry free for 30 nights
with free shipping
and returns so try them you got nothing
to lose plus
the joint listeners get an exclusive 15
off
your first set of sheets with promo code
joey
at
bowlandbranch.com bo
b-o-l-l and branch b-r-a-n-c-h
dot com
promo code joey the best sheets in the
business let's get this party started
it's a wednesday and it's the first of
the month
we got no time to [__] around
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to another fun-filled
wednesday joint
uncle joey it's september 1
30 days from the many saints in newark
i know a lot of years are [__] happy
i'm happy i can't wait for this to come
out
and get this [__] over with already
enough with the [__] suspense
that's it the rent is due and the rent
is due [__] the moratorium is
[__] up jack you better sell those
stamps
you better sell those [__]
bonds your grandmother gave you remember
you thought you were going to college
you dumb [__] you ain't going to college
no more you got to pay that rent my
heart goes out to a lot of people
a lot of shit's going on i was talking
to my friend over in uh la
and he was telling me that his weed
store was not doing that [__] well
like people are just not [__] coming
out but on the other hand laughing gas
is alive and kicking good weed is good
weed i [__] somebody sent me an email
from them the other day that
uh people are [__] selling laughing
gas
like fake laughing gas in l.a when
does it [__] end this and then you
ask me like joey what the [__] why are
you like this because
people don't [__] stop and i'm not
angry i'm not mad it doesn't surprise me
you know for years people have been
selling joey dears weed i don't even
[__] i never even smoked that [__]
weed i'm not there to [__] okay
the only weed i've ever okay is laughing
gas that's it that's the only weed i
have up in the market and if you don't
get it at the ice cream shop you're not
really getting laughing gas guys so
it's up to you if you want to get fake
laughing gas i will let you know what
stores is on what you do is you go to
laughing gas
on instagram
follow them and i will keep you posted
as soon
as they start going into the stores
we're going to go through southern
california northern california
vegas
colorado and then these two [__]
states whatever the [__] they decide to
get their [__] together jersey and new
york even though
my friends go to weed stores in jersey
and
they like it they're having a great time
they're getting good weed you know it's
not
some of the [__] i show up with but it
gets you [__] high and you know it
does the trick no you don't need to get
it from cali you don't you know it's
no big [__] deal it's like people
still ask me about the stars the stars
have been out of business for four
[__] years get your [__] clocks
fixed but on the other hand you don't
need the stars
you can make great edibles at home
that's what i don't understand about
people they can make great edibles at
the house if i [__] put my head to it
i'll make you a [__] brownie i mean i
don't know how to make gummies and all
that other [__] i'm not joe the [__]
baker but any [__] [__] can make
[__] brownies with some nuts in them
and i'll [__] you up you ask my wife
about the brownies i make i mean i i
don't know nothing about nothing i take
a little butter i take a little [__]
olive oil
i cut the weed really [__] small i
just keep cutting it cutting it cutting
it if you want to throw an eighth of
that in there that's all you [__]
need for the regular pan of betty
crocker that's all you need is just a
[__] eight to some good weed cut that
[__] cut it cut it cut it keep
cutting it cut it cut it don't run it
through a grinder cut it
because if you run it through a grinder
the [__] that that [__]
breaks off and it has a catch in the
bottom and then you i use i have maybe
three ounces of keith that i'm thinking
about [__] you do a little olive oil
first you don't burn the olive oil you
throw a little [__] butter in there
nice
you keep the flame [__] low i'm no
chef of the future i just watched bobby
flay from time to time you keep that
[__] flame low and you keep pushing
that will you take just let's say you
have an eighth
that'll that'll give you probably
three times you can put fresh weed in
you make your brownie batch right i make
my brownie
batch i have it ready and then while i'm
frying the [__] weed
i press into that weed and i take all
the juice out of it and i put it in the
[__] thing then i put the frying pan
back i throw some more wheat in there
some more olive oil i leave the old weed
in there and i keep [__] cooking but
i stir this [__] i'm like uh
henry hill's [__] brother and
goodfellas remember stir the sauce
that's me i'm just stirring the [__]
brownie mix and then i [__] throw
more weed in this [__] and i get
that [__] going i squeeze it
more i put it in the [__] weed and
then i stir it more and more and more
and i'm [__] crazy afterward and
every time i do it you lick that [__]
spoon every time you [__] finish
[__] spinning it around listen you
don't even eat the brownies to cook
you'll be [__] up before the brownies
even come out of the [__] oven the
brownies would be what you eat because
of the [__] munchies then you're
gonna get more [__] munchies it's
tremendous it's it's a great [__]
cycle i don't know if you've ever done
it or not but i love all that craziness
that's just me dog
yeah little laughing gas brownies you'll
be [__] i don't know if i want to
spend that weed on my brownies though
because it tastes good you got to use
weed that is strong but doesn't taste
good you ever have your friend that
brings you that [__] mexican weed
that tastes like [__] a dead taco but
your eyes get [__] red you can light
a cigarette in your eyeballs from how
high you are that's the weed you need
when the weed tastes good that's why
when they make crack when they started
making crack it was a coke
you're going to see in this interview
you're going to learn about washing
cocaine i got kate quigley on today we
were talking about washing cocaine with
different [__]
uh you know
gasoline and [__] acetone and all
that [__] i don't even know what we're
talking about who gives a [__] i'm all
[__] confused it's wednesday
[__] september 1st you bad
[__] i'm feeling good i'm looking
good labor day is here
you know college football is here it's a
whole new [__] season you can't dress
in white after [__] monday that said
it's over put your white clothes away
you [__] white people with your
little white clothes on hahaha somebody
was telling me one of my neighbors told
me they had to go to a wedding in the
[__] uh
the night before they had to go to the
[__] rehearsal dinner dressed in
white hat
why
why you know she sucked 50 dicks already
well you know what's the big [__]
deal what i [__] hate weddings i
really do and i'm back in jersey where
people talk about them and they actually
go to weddings like i had a friend i
gotta go to boston for a wedding what
i wouldn't go to boston for a wedding if
you [__] paid me put a deuce in the
envelope
and tell them give them a hip and a
[__] hoe you know what i'm saying i
don't want to go no [__] weddings
right now i'm all wetting the [__] out
man and you got to put and if you don't
know the people it's it's terrible
because the wife she's walking around
like she never sucked a dick before get
it together you've had 10 dicks in your
mouth and now you know everybody has to
dress in white give me a breather come
on remember when you suck dick outside a
white castle now you're trying to be
[__] uh you know
i can't stand that [__] people forget
that [__] past that's why i'm happy i
don't forget who the [__] i am i know
i'm a [__] criminal i know i'm a
dirty bastard and guess what i love it
and i'm saying it's who the [__] i am i
think i'm gonna be walking around like
eric clapton making [__] vaccination
songs he's going off that [__]
that motherfucker's been going over eric
you're 75 you're the fan who gives a
[__] nobody wants to see you on the road
anyway last time i saw her clapping on
the road he was really [__] good he
did uh a blues album and he toured it
people were pissed he didn't do layla
who gives a [__]
you know but guess what i don't want to
see harry clapton no more he's about 80.
slow hand is officially [__] slow
hand you know you know he's not going to
play lay down sally and [__] so but
anyway it's a fun-filled day and it's
wednesday so that means there's an
interview upon us it's not just me
giving you a [__] hear beating like
monday on marriage today we got a good
guest she's a dear friend of mine
um
you know
this past years gave me a chance to
reflect on what happened the last 23
years
that's all this has been it's just a
reflection here
on what the [__] happened the last 23
years how did i get to point a
how did i get to the longest yard you
know the people i met what happened to
this guy what happened to that guy
you're going to hear me talking before
that i just finally
started mourning jeff scott the piano
player from the store you know i had so
much on my plate
when he passed away i never even had a
chance to mourn him properly you know
but i got a chance to think about my
friends who were my friends out there
who i loved and uh
you know i spoke to kate after i moved a
few times she had her own life you know
she was going on the road she had a
little dilemmas
and somewhere along the line we lost
contact for a month or two during my
surgery and stuff
and we started talking and i realized
how much i loved him how much i enjoyed
kate you know you always have to have a
you have to have a couple female friends
that you don't have sex with
that's some of our biggest problems as
men that
we see a woman we think we have to have
sex with her i knew as a young man
you're not going to have sex with
everybody and you got to keep some women
on your corner because you never [__]
know look what happened to me last year
who stuck up for me the women did the
women got me out of that [__] mess
all of a sudden i've known him for years
he's not that type of person so you have
to have if you're a comic whatever the
[__] you are in your life
you work with some women you know
you're next to women every day i know
that sometimes you say to yourself she's
got nice tits i wouldn't mind eating a
[__] but you can't think that way you
got to keep some women as friends
it's a great [__] experience to have
a female friend i i love it
you know it's it's sad that here i don't
have that many female friends like you
have friends from high school and stuff
but they're married they have their own
things going on you know they're my age
uh i need like a young friend like a
girl just to
just to bounce [__] off tomorrow at the
gym i have a friend at the gym that's a
great girl she's 24. she's a nurse up in
the bronx and she's a good friend of
mine we talk all the time so she's been
kind but she's been out of town the last
three weeks she went to albania and she
went to mexico everybody's a [__]
travel now
but i'll get to see you tomorrow anyway
you put it listen enjoy kate quigley
she's one of my dearest friends i love
her to death
enjoy [__]
[Music]
oh what's up beautiful oh my god you
look beautiful
thanks just for you i put on makeup holy
[__]
yeah okay quickly it's been a year
i can't believe it holy [__] holy [__] i
just want to
stare at you me too i want to stay on
you can you hear me okay i want to turn
you up a little louder i can hear you
you look beautiful
you look great with a sun
it's fake but thank you that's great
well you just spray it on i've been
getting spray pans
do you go like a bed or something and
they [__] just
i bring her to my house
you're a
what's that you just do the front
no no i said if i could do the back
myself i would just do it okay
okay girl she she does the whole thing
for you the back the front
yeah the whole thing i wear a bikini
because i want it to look real so i have
like tan lines and everything
you're a [__] nut you know how was
the weekend in canada
it was so fun man it's like weird
canada i think is easier
you can't go
no you can't go though right yeah
i'm not allowed in canada
they won't let me and they won't forgive
me
i was sneaking in there
you are not i swear to god the last two
or three times i snuck into canada
wait you just like walked in through
like a hidden location no before 9 11
if you went to buffalo
canada has casinos
oh yeah and they have a casino
right there on uh
on the uh border
so i had a friend in miami who dated a
girl
in miami
that was from buffalo
so i was talking to him one day and i
got to go to [__] canada i got to
sneak in they're not going to let me in
and he goes i got you because my
father-in-law
is like a [__] high roller at this
casino and there's a side entrance
so
what he would do is i'd i'd go fly to
buffalo the guy would pick me up take me
to his house feed me with his wife
yeah and then he would go to the casino
he was just an old italian guy
stop you at the border at all
like there's no not him
not at that time it was pre-911 still
they would let him go into the casino
and then he would pull out and take me
to the bus stop in uh ontario canada
and i would take that bus to toronto or
montreal or wherever the [__] i was
going
but the fun part kate started on the way
back
because i would go through the border
yeah oh so they're like they didn't know
you were there in the first place no and
they would type my name and they would
go what the [__] how did you get in here
when did you come through i go last week
you were here
i didn't let you in don't put that on me
i kept doing this awesome
that's so funny
i got stopped well last time i played uh
niagara falls i flew into buffalo just
because i guess it was like cheaper or
whatever and the guy picked me up and
we're going across the border and i had
an opener i forget who i brought but
we're almost to the border the guy goes
hey you guys don't do a blow right
and we were both like i mean every once
in a while maybe the guy goes all right
well the last comics i brought through
they took their keys and their credit
cards and they swiped them so the guy
goes if you think there's even remote
residue
uh wipe them off so the kid that was
with me pulls his keys out starts
sucking on all his keys like trying to
get everything up we'd get there he was
so high i was like you should have
handed them around the car
but we made it through let me tell you
something i had a key that was [__]
black
like the shots from the coke from all
those years god knows how i didn't get
hepatitis c
b
isn't that crazy yeah because those keys
are filthy those dollar bills that you
roll up and put in your [__] nose
yeah
not to mention everybody who's like
terrified of the vaccine that i know in
la who will do blow up like the back of
a toilet seat in a dirty bar but they're
like i can't put anything in my body
that's what i was saying a couple of
weeks ago all these [__] that
did pills and coke
do you know one night i was watching
like narcos
years ago when it first came out
the season with pablo and i gotta tell
you something i was pretty bummed the
[__] out because when you find out what
they put in coke you're like
what the [__] was i snorting all those
years i haven't watched it i haven't
watched any of those gasoline turpentine
falls oh i'm sure you know they put so
much [__] in the [__] cocaine to wash
it
i still remember snorting coke kate that
smelled so bad
because there was a time way before you
were even born there was a time in the
80s when
the biggest problem was getting ether
into colombia
it wasn't getting cocaine up ether is
what you use to wash it it's what gives
it that nice little taste and that smell
but when they didn't have ether you know
the stuff that's a nail polish remover
yeah you have a little nail polish
removed it smells [__] great
no way yes
oh that's so chill you i think well
that's what's in blow that's what they
wash it with and when they don't have
ether or acetone
they use gasoline or [__] turpentine
or
i could tell that i've smelled that you
know the whole pandemic i mean it really
turned me off it completely because i
think like uh well first of all you were
alone like i was so alone at the
beginning of lockdown joey i didn't see
anybody for probably three months
at least two months three months it was
terrible yeah yeah and i couldn't go see
my family or anything you know because
my mom's lupus so she's like autoimmune
and
even after the vaccines i mean she's
still high risk so i can't go there much
but i was by myself and i was like you
can't sit alone at home and drink and do
like i would have gone crazy if i was
doomed yeah so i just worked out a lot i
looked a lot better and then i got happy
and i got fat and now i'm getting back
in shape
you look great you look great you look
great i've been really the last time i
slept nine [__] hours
last night i haven't slept nine hours in
40 [__] years and the night before
that i slept eight and a half years i
sleep great here you know i'm on a
[__] timer
11 30 i go upstairs nappy nunu i get up
at eight this morning i got up at
[__] nine
wait a minute there's a nap at noon no i
go upstairs at 11 30 at night
oh love i was wondering that cause like
a couple times i text you around
probably 12 12 30 your time
that's the difference with my life that
i'm paying attention to little things i
didn't pay attention to before
because you got to take care of yourself
now you know this [__] catches you in a
vulnerable minute
you know you're out [__] 30 hours
you're not sleeping that's when this
[__] slip slips into your body you know
so
yeah not just that but uh also i think
just this whole thing made me appreciate
like the stuff in my life that i mean
comedy is obviously like we love it and
comedy i realized this past weekend how
much comedy helps me to work through
[__] that's in my head too like we're so
fortunate that we get to work out
everything in our lives and make it
funny like we have to make it funny but
it helps me kind of like process things
in a weird way and this pandemic
especially like
i really realized how much i missed just
working out my family the beach i moved
to the beach i'm so much happier at the
beach i love being here i surf i go
surfing i suck at it i like can barely
stand up but it's fun how's venice
looking it's still looking like a
[__] war zone
actually no they moved a lot of those
tent uh tents out but you know all of la
i mean it's there's still so much
homeless here it's it's kind of deadline
is tomorrow i think
what's that the judge gave them until
tomorrow or october 1st one of those so
they better get to chop chopping those
[__]
you know what's weird is the block i'm
on at the end of the block is hunter
biden joe biden's kid so they he lives
like four houses down from me so they
put secret service on my block so i'm so
lucky because it became the safest block
in the neighborhood
so you [__] scored
yeah i'd go over there too all the time
and just talk to him and stuff then one
night i thought i had a stalker i had
this creepy guy hanging around my place
for like about a week and i went over
there and told secret service and they
were walking by like every hour checking
on my place it was awesome
so i feel happy tremendous
yeah those are kind of hot
are they
yeah i mean two of them are pretty hot
but i think they're not allowed to like
you know
yeah
nah those [__] mingle they pay
for [__] with government money their
dirty bastards remember when they went
to columbia and they all went to a strip
club and [__]
and they got in trouble yeah nervous no
way [__] yeah who are they with who are
they protecting i think obama
that's hilario
you know that
i mean i would imagine he'd ought to be
because he's too clean yeah he's too
cool something's got to go off there
yeah if you can't find a scandal you
know there's lots of scandals i i'm
grateful because i spoke to my ex-drug
dealer
during the pandemic like i kept in touch
with him
you know he was lonely he lives by
himself he lives by himself so
i made a point to call everybody who was
single
you know
stay in touch with like dean delray
you know i mean i was having a hard time
and i got a wife and a kid
what about the people that are [__]
alone in that apartment all day
there's no friday saturday weekend
you're not going anywhere
so i would contact like every day i made
it like even for my self-help you know
for my mentor
being
like let me reach out to these single
people and i started talking to my drug
dealer and it was funny because he's
like i can't [__] talk to you right
now
i'm busy i gotta deliver coke he was
busier during the pandemic
wow he ever was he says he was selling
numbers that he never even touched
before you're kidding no he went from
like selling an ounce let me put this
away he went from selling an ounce a
week to three ounces a week
wow well if you think about it i mean
nobody was spending money on anything no
he was saying that he couldn't figure
out where people were getting all the
money from
the liquor store
the liquor stores were [__] packed
you know one of mercy's karate teachers
is a liquor salesman and he's like you
have no [__] idea the numbers of
tito's he sells tito's
i definitely bought a lot more booze
than usual during the fandom
but i never got my unemployment either
like it was really hard in la for uh
self-employed people even though they
said they came out with unemployment
money for us but it was basically like
you know when you act how they take
taxes out like if it's a sag job or
whatever so if you had like two or three
jobs where they took taxes they would
base your unemployment on that instead
of your stand-up money so like you're
getting you know if you made five grand
in the whole year acting but you made 50
grand doing stand-up your unemployment
was based on the w-2 money so it was
like nothing like i got literally 300
bucks total or something it was nothing
it was rough i was stealing i was
stealing ice cream
i was like stealing food from cvs
i'm not even going everybody's stealing
everybody's robbing the [__] cbs now
from walmart everybody people are just
taking [__] and walking out and showing
security here you go thank you i mean
you have a mask a hat sunglasses it's
like what are they i mean really you
could rob anywhere it was the best time
to rob anyway i didn't rob anywhere but
i did just ice cream i took
and popcorn a little pop
nothing wrong with that man you had to
[__] survive you had to do what you
had to do you know yeah you're a single
woman and the land of alligators out
there and uh yeah
it was crazy what's your love life now
have you seen any dicks lately what's
going on
i saw so many dicks in canada actually
but not like no but i didn't have sex
with them i just i realized that in
canada all the men's rooms the doors are
wide open like every bar nobody closes
the door so i was at a club well there
wasn't a club a bar i walked by the
men's room and i'm not kidding it was
like eight guys peeing and it was just a
clear shot like a row of dicks so
i didn't touch any but i said
no
you gotta knock on the door guys can i
sniff one of those just to get me back
in the [__] game let me sniff one of
those
p soaked dicks pizza dick um
no i uh it was funny canada was so
hilarious because the drinking age there
was 18.
you forget that so like one night after
the show these guys were like meet up
with us at this bar and i was like
that'd be fun they're kind of hot why
not i go to this bar like about 30
minutes later it's packed with like 18
to 22 i had to be the oldest person in
there by like 15 years at least and i
couldn't find these guys i hung out for
about an hour looking for them
and then i just stayed for the
entertainment because every time i went
in the bathroom there's like five girls
crying and girls kept telling me how
pretty i was and touching my hair and
then they were asking me for advice and
telling me i was wise so i just stayed
there and hung out and was like the
bathroom therapist for the rest of the
day
i love hanging out with you because you
always break it down like
i'll never forget being at the comedy
store where you and that chick showed up
that sucks like 20 dicks online
don't say her name because i don't want
to [__] hear it
remember you remember she was a blonde
she's cute
she came into the comedy store you were
sitting next to me
you're like let me tell you something
i'm crazy but that chick
is [__] crazy she is crazy she is
insane and her husband they're both nuts
now you met her and her husband
yeah i met them at a show i forget with
town it was on the road they came to a
show and afterwards we went to a gay bar
okay this chick i mean i like her if she
if they watch this i like them both they
don't like her i really like
what it wouldn't
if i was single i'd really [__] like
her oh dude we went to a bar after the
show that was like it was like
applebee's it wasn't like a crazy bar
and people were asking her for photos
they kind of knew who she was and she
was taking her tits out for pictures in
this family right i mean there weren't
kids i saw but it also wasn't a place to
take your tits out but no one was really
complaining or anything
and then we went to uh
a gay bar and i don't even know how
her husband got kicked out somehow i
don't even know what happened i mean one
minute he was fine the next minute he
was like sweating he probably took like
a molly or something he's like yelling
at people and then some guy started
hitting on him and he was like you're
not my type and the guy before i knew it
they were kicked out like i don't even
know what happened and then they hit me
up to come to their room later and i was
like this is probably not my
probably not the best time for me to get
arrested so i stayed
and then you didn't see it until that
time at the comedy store with me
never again till then wow
yeah yeah she was the comedy store that
night she sat down in the back
she had the other porno chick with a
i was watching it very closely i was
talking to people but you know like when
you're talking to people but you're
watching people
and i'm watching it and she's like i
gotta suck a dick
like what was coming out of her mouth
was [__] crazy
she's so nice though she's very sweet
and she's hot you know that's what
confuses you like she's really [__]
hot but at the same time she's talking
about breaking her record
sucking dicks and all this [__] so
finally i couldn't take it no more
so i told i said do you make videos
because i didn't really know what you
just told me she was crazy and [__] and
i didn't know her either and it all came
to me after she was yakking
because she was talking about sucking 10
dicks at a [__] pool or something
like that so i was like did you make a
video because i saw she puts her videos
up on twitter
oh which is [__] surreal because you
could be getting up at six in the
morning you know you're out of it you're
drinking coffee you put twitter you
scroll and there's her [__] like 10
dudes
that's i haven't seen that i actually
have um believe it or not i have like
the graphic nudity muted on my twitter
just because i get on twitter on the
plane so much and i just don't want like
the grandma sitting next to me to have
to
view every time i open my phone it's
like if it's the last thing i watch it's
usually porn because that's all i really
use my phone for when i get on
you know chrome so
so i try not to show it to everybody
so yeah she makes videos
and after she was talking like wait a
second
i saw one of your videos
and she goes i got like 10 guys [__]
you but the whole the the reason why the
video i stopped and watch it i hate porn
but the reason why i watched it was
because
there's like six guys around the [__]
uh they're she's sucking their dicks you
know they're coming up
but there's one guy in the corner
like the ugly chick at the prom
she's just in the corner jerking off by
herself right like he's jerking off
i swear to god so they're all around
they're like [__] barracudas
they're [__] they're hitting it with
dicks and [__] and there's a guy in the
corner by himself just whacking off
so i said is that your video of like six
guys [__] you i felt bad saying it to
her but i didn't know how else to say it
i'm like is that you with the video with
six guys i go there was a guy in the
corner jerking off it may not be you she
goes that was me she goes that guy in
the corner that's a complete different
story so she was telling me
that he's on paper not paypal what's the
[__] that you show people your [__]
only fans
i'm on there and i don't even she's not
and she has raffles or or contest
to [__] her or jerk off honor or
whatever so he won the contest so she
invited him to the gang bang and he's
just in the corner jerking off so she
told me she goes you're not going to
believe the story
at the end of the night
i asked him if he had a good time and he
goes yeah
so she asked him do you want to [__] me
you were the contest winner and he goes
not really i just want to hug you
and he laid next to her and they
they uh what do you call that when you
spoon they spooned each other no she
said she threw him out like an hour
later he wouldn't [__] her he just
wanted to spoon her and suck his thumb
like a [__] [__] can you
believe that i swear
would you want to watch a girl get
[__] by 10 dudes and then put your
dick in there well you're there
no i know
i'm not that type of duty they would
freak me out to get sloppy seconds
after everybody but you got to find the
hole something even just put your
fingers like this
you know what i'm saying i mean you
already [__] 10 guys yeah put your
fingers like this do something so i can
put my you know something the guy was
like i just want a spoon with you and he
spoon and that was the end of it
you know it is weird when you have to
ask somebody something like that but you
know it's what they do but you still
feel weird right i felt [__] weird
like i felt like she was going to press
charges on me but she was talking all
about it and there was witnesses there
you follow me like it wasn't just me and
her so she could say well he was sexual
with me that was we were outside we were
in the back people were smoking pot god
yeah yeah god rest his soul the piano
player and all those people were back
there so when he's back there i could
say anything to anybody because
he's honest and people believe him the
gay guy that died
yeah yeah yeah scott jeff
jeff i miss him man it hit me like three
months ago that he was dead and i
[__]
i was driving somewhere and i just broke
down
somebody said they went back to the
store and it's not the same without jeff
he hasn't been
i'd like uh have moments like that with
eric myers you know what i mean eric
myers was a weird one for me because
i mean it sounds so odd to say this but
you'll get it because you've had friends
who are addicts like i almost felt in a
way happy for him when i first heard it
was like
i was shocked but i wasn't all the way
shocked because you know
you kind of expect at some point when
somebody falls off the wagon that many
times you like prepare yourself but then
the big thing was he was always so
anxious
like even sober that i felt like you
could finally chill out but i didn't
really feel it until like it was like
last week some photo popped up of me and
eric in las vegas just having fun
together and it suddenly hit me i was
like it's weird that people that died
during this
because you already haven't seen them in
a while so then it's like it doesn't
really hit you until a moment where you
would see them or memory or something at
least for me i found it really bad for
eric myers i wasn't best friends with
eric myers
but i cared for him as a comic because
he was really good
really do you know what i'm saying when
somebody's really good you look at them
and even if you're not
best friends with them yeah you have the
secret adoration for them
oh he's incredible he was you know he
lived in my kitchen right yeah he told
me i remember yeah yeah
yeah
he was always at the haha i became
friends with him at the ha
yeah about eight years ago before mercy
was born about nine years ago i would
walk my wife
to the train station in the mornings and
he would be going to an a.a meeting
oh really way up there i didn't know he
went up there i remember he lived with
the agostino for a while
that's right he kind of lived with
everybody for a while yeah i love him he
was a good kid you know i i felt bad for
the way he went
yeah you know usually when an addict
dies
when somebody says to me well this guy
owed you know what are you gonna do that
was his life you know that was
what he was shocked he never did i was
shocked
i was shy i never oh deed [__] tom
seguro did when he was in college i've
never odd
that is shocking that is shocking that
tom seguro did not never [__] know
deep but
it's uh when he
passed and i got the call that he got
hit by a boss or something
i immediately lit a candle and i felt
bad i felt bad for him i felt bad for
his family
and i got to be tell you something
honestly i was a little angry with him
me too because the talent was so [__]
good like he was he was so great if he
would have put the drinking aside but it
listen he tried so hard that's the thing
he tried so [__] and he was like
eric was the most extreme case i've ever
seen of somebody that was so different
the second he fell off it was like he
would go from the sweetest most
sensitive guy to
i mean one sip might as well be five
fifths of vodka he just could not stop
and he would he would pass out he showed
up one time naked at my house at two in
the afternoon naked in the middle of the
day in hollywood he'd been missing for
like three days he was all beat up and
stuff i mean he just there was no
moderation whatsoever it was zero to a
million you know the the way he went
did not shock me
to be totally honest with you because i
just i know that he would get to the
point of he had no idea where he was
what he was doing i mean
yeah he would every time it was funny
though
every time eric would fall off the wagon
everything he owned would get stolen or
sold right so every time he'd need new
clothes
and so he didn't want to buy expensive
clothes so he would go to hollywood
highland and buy just those souvenir
t-shirts all he ever wore were those
like hollywood souvenir t-shirts all the
time everything he owned said like
hollywood boulevard or man's chinese
theater or whatever the [__] they were
like those four for ten dollar shirt
deals
he's awesome i miss him a lot but he was
also so such a good writer i mean he was
a great writer that's what the jealousy
was from i was [__] jealous i would
see him
perform at ah and i'm like that kid
is dangerous but then i saw his drinking
yeah you know and this is crazy i gotta
tell you there's like five comics i've
known that
they let the booze and the drugs get in
front of their talent
yeah and i remember when i made my
decision 14 years ago i was like i'm not
getting nowhere in comedy i'm doing
movies
i'm doing all this [__] but i'm not
getting anywhere and it was like this
has to be the answer
wow so let's push it aside for a minute
and see if this is the answer thank god
it's stuck
yeah thank god yeah thank god
and i didn't go back to it i didn't
[__] relapse
and i was done with it like once i was
away from it for three weeks i'm like
i'm done with it
that was the victory it wasn't uh
succeeding in comedy
then what ended up happening was you
know you take away that drug focus
and all you have left is comedy
yeah so you really like it
yeah it's just a lot easier when you're
not waking up going well tonight you
know when you're [__] on drugs you
wake up in the morning and you're like
i'm not gonna do coke
but it's still on your [__] mind also
though like like i literally feel like
two days of nothing
i mean the energy is insane just two
days even have no drinks like because
for me
i would have a drink like every night
after a set at least one two drinks
every night and then
i went home
uh about a year ago for just a few days
to ohio and three days or something like
when i'm in ohio i don't really drink my
mom there's no liquor in the house
i i was like wow this is like taking
five adderall just being sober i mean
it's like crazy how much more energy i
had i woke up like really happy so
now i've taken i take breaks all the
time
and i look better when i do that so i'm
very vague
that's much better i gotta tell you
something i went to uh
i went to a get-together a few weeks ago
and i knew a lot of the women there you
know i had grown up with them
and i tell you something that's sad i
could tell
the women that drank
and the women that didn't
i could tell a big difference yeah there
was one woman that was beautiful growing
up i don't know what the [__] happened
to her nose it looks like she'd been
smelling farts the last 20 [__] years
her nose got so [__] thick i wouldn't
invite her to do coke at
how does all happen i don't know it's
either you're smelling farts
i don't think that's good i sat on your
[__] nose you know i lost weight my
nose got bigger like sometimes your nose
gets bigger but it got bigger that way
like you know your nose did not get
bigger
you got a [__] flute in front of my
face and [__] you're hilarious but
you could tell that it really affects
women alcohol and it affects men too
you know it affects us too you know we
don't look too good if you drink every
[__] day
yeah and the cigarettes
it all [__] adds up you know i love i
love [__] smoking a good cigarette
you got the wrong [__] a good
marlboro after you smoke a joint whoo i
don't like it i don't like it but you
know what i've really gotten into
what you're saying sorry normal light
after you smoke a [__] fat joint
oh my god i don't miss that i don't miss
being around it either i uh
i did start micro dosing mushrooms
during this whole pandemic and holy [__]
that has helped me so much everything
anxiety
oh my god joey life changing
i get so much less stressed out than i
used to i like
when i i don't know it's just it really
makes me happier and it's just the
babiest little i mean you know a tad
little tiny teeny bite like i can't feel
high i don't feel anything but i'm
happier
it's crazy that i've been reading a lot
about micro dosing lately a lot more
like people i just was reading something
they just opened the ketamine treatment
center
all right i've heard about that i've
never tried it a friend of mine did it
he went you know you you shoot it and
then you talk to a therapist and they
do you shoot it like a shot i didn't
know that yeah they iv you you know they
give you like an iv i think i think
that's what he said yeah they gave you
an iv
it's pretty interesting and you look
good so it must be working the micro
dose and i gave away all my [__]
mushrooms now i'm pissed
because
because people can get it
i gave them away because i had no use
for them you know what are the chances
of me eating the [__] two mushrooms
in the afternoon so i gave them to
somebody who's gonna [__] eat them
quickly
so they don't develop mold in my drawer
so i gave them away
is it bad if they get mold i thought
they are mold i don't know i just don't
i think it's okay
you grind them up right you put them in
a capsule or you bite it
um i've had the capsules but i just take
i just break a little piece off and eat
it once or twice a day so small that's
it
even with like i gave up the reefer for
like five or six months i wasn't smoking
at all
you know when i was doing the longest
yard i was over smoking on the longest
yard
we all were there was a group full of
the actors football players the
wrestlers we were smoking as much as we
could you know as long as i would bring
an ounce every [__] day
nelly would bring an ounce you know
everybody had a [__] ounce of weed on
that set and i remember one day the
costume girl she was a little older
really pretty from new york
at the time she was like maybe 55 real
good looking chick yoga
clean living you know flip-flops nice
toenails the whole [__] deal
we were talking and she told me i go you
don't smoke and she goes no i did
for a long time like you did
but once you stop
the day you stop you you're not gonna
want to stop
but the day you stop you're gonna see
life's [__] beauties
huh and i was like what is she [__]
talking about i'm seeing life's beauties
every [__] day when i get stung this
is [__] wence talking about i tell
you what man i thought about it
when i was clean those months because it
was i was seeing life for what it was
and now i'm in them
i'm in like a vac because i don't smoke
in the daytime no more kate
at all wow at all holy cow that's not
even in my favor
yeah i only smoke right after i drink my
tea
and like an hour before i go to bed to
get me there
i'm so proud of you yeah
yeah that's great man i had to do you
know it was just getting to i looked at
the things that were i was doing that
were too out of control
what could have been cleaned up in my
life now that i'm here and that was one
of the things i felt you know my coffee
drinking
i love staying up at night kate nobody
likes i don't like it and i don't like
watching tv at night and writing a
little bit and practicing your guitar
but dog i get away with you know it's
like every night oh just another half
hour
let me watch this another half hour let
me play the guitar another ten minute
next you know it's two in the [__]
morning
yeah one of those jerk-offs and then i'm
up at seven with mercy you know in the
morning talking to him whatever and then
you walk around the whole day like what
the [__] no i don't want to do and you
know i was drinking you know what i was
i wasn't sleeping in l.a right i was
sleeping like you know two to seven
five yeah you weren't sleeping at all no
and then guess what i was staying up
espressos
and that tastes [__] told between the
[__] stevia the [__] you know i
wasn't just doing
two espressos like a normal
person i was doing eight a day
even two at night and a lot
i was doing four
that's insane you were doing 84 i left
the house
it was a coffee mug
filled with espresso
that's that you know what espresso like
that gets me so anxious and jittery like
worse than anything i can't i barely
drink coffee you know i have like a half
a cup if i have it
it's like speed to me every morning and
that's it
no more
i listen this is my coffee life in la
an american coffee then a double
espresso then i'd wash my [__]
i do what i have to do i realize that
the energy drinks you drink before you
work out are [__] oh yeah so i would
drink an espresso or two and go to jiu
jitsu with brett
oh my god
i can't do that
i can't work
oh my god then i would come home and pop
another one
around five just a single i was telling
myself just a single joey you'd be fine
and then i would eat dinner you know do
whatever i had to do but before i shot
to the store
it was a four [__] shot espresso
cuban style and then how does that do
anything after all that it can't do
edible
so i was forcing the anxiety and i mean
i get down to the store and i look at
the comics on the stage and i go how am
i going to follow him i i suck
man and then i start [__] in my head
oh my god you have no idea and then i
get this [__] anxiety and remember
when they close
the original room was fine for me it
still is you know i don't want people to
think i'm a [__] mook
but when they tape that window
when they take it from
the window oh to the front bar to me to
the front bar that killed yeah i loved
that window that was my little [__]
anxiety window i would look out the
window when i was on stage
i was okay
i don't remember having that
where you couldn't look out when did
they have it so you can you can still
use for 20 [__] years they had it for
15 years they had it that you could look
out
no i know i mean i didn't i don't
remember when you couldn't look out you
can't look out before they closed it
yeah before i left oh
i didn't realize before i left you
couldn't look in anymore
oh well then they reopened it yeah
that's when i started getting anxiety
was when i couldn't see outside
oh yeah i hate that you know like when
you hear a police siren and you're on
stage you want to know why this you know
what direction he's going and [__]
now you can't [__] see where the cops
going because the window's [__]
blocked
yeah that i don't like that it's like
when you're out i hate when i'm on a
plane and it's starting to land and
everybody has all their windows closed
and nobody opens it like i don't like to
be on a plane that's landing and i can't
see what's happening here i'm in the
window i don't give a [__] open that
window guy
you tell him i don't tell people i'm
super late and then the [__] store
this comes on can you please close the
windows because other people gonna come
and want to keep the
the plane cool go [__] yourself keep the
other one
only turning the [__] around on it's
90 [__] degrees in here i got to tell
you something that you brought up before
here's the funny thing a lot of people
don't know
i didn't know this and it changed my
life and when i found out i was hesitant
about it i didn't do it for like five
times
and then i did it and i was at peace
with myself you ready
yeah whenever you work
on a tv show
or anything
a commercial
a tv show a movie
the [__] day that [__] movie
wraps or that commercial raps or that tv
show wraps
you get unemployment on the phone
oh yeah did you know i always did that i
always did that yeah when i had my tv
show yeah [__] saved me
oh yeah even a commercial from 2008 to
2000 like 11 12
i collected unemployment
because for all those years
i worked i did movies commercials tv
shows and i never collected then ari
told me the mind of the jew ari goes dog
after all those commercials i [__]
how did you not know i thought that
everybody in l.a no i didn't know and it
was like oh wow it's like an
illegitimate kind of scam
like you work one day and you can file
for unemployment and then if you work
you just take it off your unemployment
they don't say nothing to you they know
you're an actor but don't you only get
it for like the length of time that you
were on the job or something i don't
know no i got it
for [__] four or five years
i was never broke again after i got on
the unemployment like i always had those
gaps of being broke like for a week
you're broke you need 200 no because
they were paying me 450 a week
oh yeah i got that 100 a month yeah so
i was like i'm staying on this
[__] they no check they just put
it on your atm card you go to the wheat
store with it you could take the cash
out
whatever that was awesome i didn't
[__] know that you could do that
oh yeah i used to do extra work i think
like even if you do extra work uh
through central casting and then you
have like a few weeks you can't get a
job or something like that you don't
give your employment so for all the
actors watching this maybe you didn't
know maybe you knew you booked a job
you're eligible for unemployment even if
it's [__] one hour on the set
yeah they'll give you unemployment no
questions asked
they'll work around your [__]
schedule the whole thing how much uh
comedy you got left this year
actually i got a bunch now thank god
like summer i actually worked quite a
bit at the beginning of like when things
were reopening before a lot of comics
wanted to work yet you know i was like
i'll go anywhere
when you get the [__] campsite tour
that was tremendous oh that was so
fun and truck stops i was like telling
jokes in a bikini at truck stops it was
so stupid it was so fun but you were
putting it together you were happy
that's what this pandemic was about
figuring out how you could put it
together and not catching [__] cobit
yeah it was really fun man and then uh
and then it was awesome it was like
really hilarious because everywhere i
would go the minute i would leave they'd
shut the city back down it was like
literally i would come and do a weekend
everything's wide open i'd leave they'd
be like phoenix is the newest hotbed for
covid austin wherever i was so i was
just kind of avoiding it and then uh
then it got real slow
and now it's picking back up i've got a
bunch of dates coming up i've got like
texas phoenix uh vancouver a whole bunch
and i'm doing this rockin wrestling
cruise it's like rock bands and
wrestling fans and like wrestlers and to
me and brad williams doing shows on it
it's going to be so fun that's in
october
how's it going
huh what rockstar is
i don't know any of the bands like
they're none i've ever heard of but it's
chris jericho's cruise do you know who
he is yes the rest of the wrestler yeah
he has a band and then it's like from
his friend's band
that sounds [__] cool where's the
cruise going to coven
i can't get out they won't let me out
send the helicopter go [__] yourself i
told you not to go on a [__] cruise
they're not going to let you get back
out in florida you have to go to [__]
mexico and [__] and
walk with the migrant kids and [__]
jump the fence
jesus christ the best is it's like uh
they asked me if i want to bring
somebody they're gonna bring a date i'm
like are you kidding me it's like all
wrestlers and wrestling like this is
gonna be like
one girl for every 25 guys and then they
were like do you want security i'm like
i have brad williams it's like a [__]
he's going to keep me safe
what brad doing these days
he's doing great he came over we went
rollerblading i saw that he went to
visit his family good for brad he's
always a good [__] dude
you know kate it's not
when we spoke a few weeks ago i realized
how much i loved you
i realized that
we were a good team
in california we always got along it was
weird you know it took me a while oh no
you froze
i froze
is that what you just i got you now
you're back now i'm back like herpes
oh god you know it's just nice to be
able to zoom with some of my friends and
do a podcast and the smoke cleared you
know like there was a lot of [__] when i
got off the plane i had to take care of
here there was no school my daughter
coveted the bus there was a thousand
things
now everything's take yeah she rides on
a bus there was no bus
so now but the bus is working we're fine
she's going back to school next thursday
she's playing softball starting tomorrow
thank [__] god
practice is back so i get to see my
favorite parents and [__] we get to sit
there and some of the parents drink i
sit there like a mooc with a blanket on
at night because it's cold that's
hilarious
that's fun man i'm living a different
life kate you know i i love it
i'm living vicariously through you guys
i look at your pictures gabriel
[__] selling out arenas and [__] and
joe coy
but at the same time i'm enjoying my
time at home i'm enjoying what i'm doing
you know
i already did my time out there on the
road you know i did all that [__] i want
to give it a breather
and i'm not putting any pressure on
myself one day when i wake up i go
tonight's the [__] night i'm getting
back on stage or tonight's not taking it
back on stage
i think that's perfect man that's the
biggest thing that i changed in terms of
just kind of one day at a time and just
being happy just doing whatever makes me
happy there's no like
end goal and it's just being happy man i
went home and saw my family too and uh
it was so funny i went to my
uh nephews band like they had like a
band show you know marching band i went
to my old football stadium where i grew
up and it was just it was so cool
to watch the band practice and just it
felt like i haven't done that since i
was probably 21 or something you know
like to go back home and do something
like that
it was it was wild i was like oh there's
the bleachers i first made out under and
like back there is where i got like
arrested the first time whatever
she was fine
it's crazy whenever i drive on route 3
whenever i go up north by the way when i
went up
north last time i thought of you because
i saw
hooties got a [__] huge
billboard on times square
why i don't know i called you
from the light i was at the light on
time squad so funny this is the biggest
[__] thing but there's a
there's a place that whenever i get on
route 3 and i drive back home
i always have to drive past my grammar
school it's right on route 3. it's
across new york motel mckinley
and i always think about one night it
got [__] it was freezing out and this
girl was like i thought you were taking
me home
are we gonna make out and all this [__]
and i'm like she was older than me by a
yeah i was like i didn't know what to do
and i'm like listen you can't come home
i can't go to your house
let's just swap spit with we had like
parker's on
we could zip up like i was thinking that
we could zip up like i could zip connect
the parkers
oh my god oh you know i'm [__]
[__]
so i'm like we'll connect the parkers
and we'll just [__] under the parker you
know when i got there you couldn't [__]
under the parka i never [__] before i
knew nothing about i was just a young
kid and we started swap and spit and
next thing you know [__]
i'll never forget this is embarrassing
she's like let's have sex so she pulled
off a little cheerleading bikini on you
know yeah skirt with the little [__]
red bikini
you show people to monkey when you kick
your leg but it doesn't show any hairs
or anything
and i never forget that
she took off her panties i was petrified
i had never i had seen a [__] before
but i had never she kept saying you're
gonna put it in i'm like hey yeah yeah
yeah yeah and i remember i put it in and
she started yelling the whole [__]
thing and squirming
and i don't know i got dizzy i don't
know if i came i don't know what
happened but when i [__] looked down
there was a little puddle of blood i
de-virginized it
there was a little puddle of blood so we
got up i don't step on the blood and
she's like oh thank you for being a
gentleman
i want to show my friends you know what
i'm saying like that it's too late to
let them smell my finger tonight
you know that's how [__] [__] i
am
so how do you know how do you know you
de-virginized her maybe she was just
getting her period i don't [__] know
i didn't ask i was too stupid to ask i
was 14. i walked home she was crying
you know she was crying because she got
divergent eyes what am i going to tell
god and all that [__]
i had to walk on and pat her back the
whole way it's going to be all right
the only embarrassing part of the story
is that she was crying after that jesus
is still gonna let you in you know she
was crying and [__]
and uh the next day i remember waking up
early and knocking on all my butts
when they cried i'm like no no it's not
a good sign
i didn't know what she was crying about
i'm like are you crying because you're
upset she's like no i'm not gonna my
husband's gonna send me back now and all
this [__] and i'm like that anyway there
was another girl that was like
yeah because there was another girl in
my in my
business law class that was a freak
when i was like a junior in high school
and she would only get [__] in the ass
because she was greek
and when you greek if you go home with a
busted [__] i swear to god if you go
home with a busted [__] your husband
could send you back so when you're in
high school you only take it in the ass
in college and you're a greek chick
because your husband will send you back
if you're a little monkey's damaged so
she would only let people [__] her in
the ass and give you [__]
so ah listen who the [__] knows i just
know she was upset
because
i divergenized her and i rubbed her back
and the next morning i got up and i went
up there with my friends like four of my
friends i'm let me show you this [__]
i busted the [__] last night you know
like
trying to be one of the macho guys
and when we got up there there was no
blood
what disappeared
where exactly was this outdoors yeah it
was outdoors there was a wall
disappeared an animal probably ate it
there was a door to the gym a back door
to the gym and there was like a wall
there so i took it behind the wall if
you were driving by you couldn't really
see behind that wall
so and plus it blocked us from the
elements
you know what i'm saying it was called
that it was like january or december
so
so i thought the blood was gonna freeze
because it was so cold out
but the next day i got there it was gone
there wasn't even like a [__] like a
sketch
like a [__] like
much blood are we talking i mean it's a
little little tiny doubt about it it was
like a puddle like maybe six inches long
a puddle
but right just to [__] disappear
jesus christ what the [__] is going on
in this world
i don't think there's that much i think
it's like just a drop of blood when you
de-virginize some i'm not sure because i
think i accidentally de-virginized
myself
you know like how sometimes you break it
by mistake on a bike or something
i never had blood the first time keep
telling yourself
you got fingered at the girl scouts and
[__]
you traded for a box of cookies
that's probably how it happened
yeah i forgot about that at the skating
rink look at these [__] fingers if i
think i'm busting everything i'm busting
your hymen
i'm busting the noodle i'm busting the
bubble for the [__] where the baby's
hidden
you're poking the heart joey you're
breaking the heart i'll poke the [__]
kidney look at these [__] gorilla
fingers this sausages
you crack me up so you got a boyfriend
now
no nothing
are you gonna stay single what's the
future like for kate quigley i'm gonna
stay single for a minute because i just
i just kind of got out of this thing and
i'm just trying to figure out sort of i
mean
i'll be honest like um
i haven't done my podcast in a while
like
this was not easy to date someone so
public for me because i'm so open you
know so
i felt kind of restricted
in terms of what i like being myself
what i can talk about and stuff so i
kind of want to find like like just get
myself back to normal so i'm just kind
of uh about to start a new podcast i'm
not gonna say the name of it but it's
really funny it's gonna be really funny
and uh and then i've just been writing a
lot and stand up and stuff like that but
oh and then the only fans i've never
been naked on my only fans i've been
using it to do like life coaching with
people and stuff like that like funny
life coaching and stuff so
um but yeah no i'm gonna stay single and
stay single have some fun for a minute
and you know that's it fun fun when are
you gonna come visit us actually i was
just talking about that with uh my buddy
uh adam from county pros i his
girlfriend's in new york while he's on
tour we're good friends so i'm gonna go
visit her so i'll be there soon maybe a
few weeks
will keep me posted any anything you
want to pump
um actually i'd have to look at my
schedule but you know follow me on
social media i post everything there and
uh go check out my only fans because i
don't have a job
so that's it
yeah you look beautiful you look happy i
miss you i'm yeah
man i miss you too so you're always
welcome here i got a spare bedroom
jim's got a spare bedroom you know you
got family here so gym's right around
the corner
so whenever you want to stop by but
please you know let's keep in touch
we've been having a good time lately
keeping in touch and it means the world
to me so
i didn't know we were [__] so tight
so
you know yeah you think you're friends
with people and then
you let the coffee sit for a while you
know and then you see what cream rises
and you rose to the top
so i appreciate you with all my heart
for being my friend and for the
friendship that we have it's funny as
[__] we talk about weird [__] all the
time eating [__] and
doing all crazy [__] but that's what
it's all about sometimes
i think that uh you know all these
rules
have [__] us up and people can't be
friends no more because you know i got
to be careful what i say
you know she's going to get pissed off
at me [__] all that [__] we're friends
yeah so
i know i love you so much man i miss i'm
so happy we did this like it's so good
to see your face me too yeah and send
you my to your mom
yeah my mom loves you my mom my mom
wants to make more uh scrunchies for
your daughter so yeah make how many you
want she'll use them all she still uses
them she showed me the other day this is
one of kate's it was a purple one so
she loves you very much so thank you for
coming on the joint today
and we will talk during the week all
right i'll call you later all right
all right
what's that you got any spots tonight or
anything uh no but i do tomorrow uh oh
i'm doing that supernova show tomorrow
and then uh the improv on thursday
hollywood improv okay i love you kate
thank you for being my friend
stay
all right bye bye
all right you bad [__]
i hope you enjoyed kate quigley i
enjoyed the [__] out her it was great to
see her she looks [__] beautiful
she's healthy
and that's all that counts right now
thank you very much
for supporting the joint for supporting
my patreon
i don't know when the nfts are coming
again i think i'm going to switch
companies and go to a different company
uh laughing gases in stock
and that's it we got 30 [__] days
to the many saints in newark that's all
that [__] matters today if you got
anything from this podcast that's what
it is today i want to thank kate but
most importantly i want to thank you
[__] for always having my back
and uh supporting the podcast have a
great labor day weekend we'll be here
monday morning for your labor day we
will have a podcast out early monday
morning for you so don't sweat the small
stuff if you got nowhere to go eat a
hamburger watch the [__] podcast and
relax with uncle joey it's that simple
don't forget college football is here
and don't forget next weekend after
labor day the 11th 12th
and 13th is [__] pro football's back
the nfl
so we're back [__] i love you
[__] have a great week have a
great labor day and i'll see you monday
morning tip top magoo now
for a word for my [__] sponsor
jack
all right i want to thank
kate quigley
but i want to thank you guys for always
having my back on a wednesday listening
supporting
and cracking [__] jokes during the
week listen the joint is brought to you
by bowling branch
there's nothing more important than a
good night's sleep
bowling branch knows it takes more than
just a good mattress you got to have
nice smooth
comfortable sheets and bowling brand
sheets are ultra soft plus they're 100
organic these sheets are soft and smooth
and comfortable i got my bed looking
sharp with my new natural colored sheets
check out the signature hem sheets
they're best sellers for a good reason
they get softer with every wash and they
come in a variety of colors
every size up the twin the california
king you were looking for a gift for
your mom your dad your aunt your
grandmother this is it and here's
something else to help you sleep all of
boiling branches products are made using
safe and fair conditions
bowling branch has a guarantee be ready
enjoy any product worry free for 30
nights now to experience the best sheets
you've ever felt
choose bowling branch you could try them
worry free
for 30 nights with free shipping and
returns
use promo code joey at
bowlandbranch.com again
bo b-o-l-l and branch
b-r-a-n-c-h
bowl and branch dot com
promo code joey you're gonna enjoy these
sheets and your family's gonna love them
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings no more [__] around the
nfl is back college football is back and
you're getting paid like a [__]
doctor because draftking sportsbook is
the official sports betting partner of
the nfl
we're going to give you a hell of an
offer you ready grab a [__] pen
if you bet one dollar on any game
you're gonna cash 200
in free bets i'm going to say it again
one dollar on any game gets you 200
and free bets instantly no matter what
you heard me right free [__] money
draftkings is giving all new players 200
bucks and free bets when you place a
dollar bet on any week one game a dollar
and you're gonna get 200 are you [__]
kidding me put down the [__]
hummus and take advantage of this
limited time offer today head to
draftkings sportsbook app today and
check out their great promotions daily
odd boost and a great [__] casino if
you like blackjack whatever the [__] you
want to do
draftkings will make your dreams come
true plus every game
has a game a same game paulie on it
but it all starts with you downloading
the draftking sportsbook app today
pressing code joey to receive 203 bets
when you place a dollar bet on any week
one game that's promo code joey to get
you 200 and free bets for a limited time
only at draftkings sportsbook app the
official sports betting partner of the
nfl a couple things to tell you got to
be 21 or older
new jersey indiana and pennsylvania only
and new customers only you got to start
from scratch restrictions apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
now do you got a gambling problem no
shame in it it happens
just call 1-800 gambler if you're in
indiana call 1-800-9
with it but if you ain't got no problems
that's the beauty about
draftkings you can't play over your head
everything is bad before you call it in
it's not like calling your bookie and
then you gotta [__] scramble on
thursday to meet him at a diner and pay
him money you ain't got that's not to
happen at draftkings download the
draftking sportsbook app because it's
time to win some [__] guitars for the
holidays
and the joint is also brought to you by
stamps.com listen
how much time you have in a day to throw
away get in your car put the boxes in
there go to the post office park get
online the guy in front of you stinks
like a [__] goat
come on
and i paid you're paying full postage
for [__] i bet you're paying full
price for postage too that's why you got
to use stamps.com you can send letters
ship packages anytime anywhere right
from your [__] computer buy
print ship
it's that simple with stamps.com you pay
a whole lot less you get discounts up to
40 percent off the post office
and up to 66 off ups rates
the discounts are stacked on stamps.com
just keep getting better and you're
still not a part of it join the family
today you got a small business a big
business i'm gonna save you thousands of
hours and loads of cash
stamps.com is a must
print us postage for any letter package
any class of mail okay
it's no wonder over a million small
businesses already use stamps.com you're
gonna ship anywhere in the world
straight from your laptop and here's the
beauty you have to get in the car
schedule a pickup and the mailman comes
to you who's better than you you can
take a walk and drop it off yourself too
but if not stamps.com is the way to go
if you're not with stamps.com you're
slipping stop wasting precious [__]
time by going to the post office go to
stamps.com instead there's no risk use
promo code joey to get a special offer
that includes a
four-week trial you're gonna get free
postage and a digital scale with
stamps.com there's no long-term
commitments or contracts either it's
that easy just go to stamps.com i'm
gonna take care of you with a four-week
trial today free postage and a digital
scale you're gonna click onto the
microphone at the top of the home page
type in joey j-o-e-y
that stamps.com
promo code joey
stamps.com
never go to the post office again i want
to thank stamps.com
i want to thank bowling branch
i want to thank draftkings
i want to thank [__]
the blue [__] whatever
blue chew the hard-on [__] king
and i want to thank you guys for
supporting and having my back that's it
we're going into another season
monday is labor day we'll have a podcast
up for you nice and early
monday morning anything else is
background music i love you
[__] with all my heart don't
forget
college football this weekend you got
baseball and then the following weekend
you're gonna download that draftking
sportsbook app today
and put your bets in for nfl better
dollar and get back 200 who takes care
of you like uncle joey bowlin brandt's
gonna take care of your stamps.com he's
gonna take a
cbd line we all take care
including your uncle joey i love you
[__] with all my heart
stay black have a great weekend
have a great labor day see you then
[__]
so
you